dernier panel politique de la semaine
est toujours en compagnie de nos fidèles
chef du bureau à québec et à ottawa à
sébastien beauvais et matane blais morin
bonsoir chers collègues
alors initions partho leuba si on veut
avec le le sujet de la journée
aujourd'hui un sujet évidemment qu'il ya
des coups partout pays surtout en cette
semaine où on a souligné la journée
nationale de la vérité et de la
réconciliation je parle ici encore une
fois du racisme systémique on en parle
aujourd'hui par le biais du rapport de
la coroner au québec géhanne kamel sur
la mort de joyce et chaque coin de
sébastien la seule recommandation qui
concerne le gouvernement du québec et
celle là de reconnaître le racisme
systémique voilà que la pression
augmente d'un cran non sur les épaules
de françois legault oui c'est une voie
plus qui s'ajoute pour demander à
françois legault de reconnaître les
racismes systémique ma compréhension
c'est que ça changera pas la position de
françois fillon est en fait des échos
que j'en ai on est vendredi il va réagir
mardi de vendredi à mardi s'il ya une
chose qu'on a appris au cours des
derniers mois c'est que bien des choses
peuvent changer
mais sur le fond aujourd'hui deux de ses
ministres et ricker et geneviève
guilbault ont tenu à peu près le même
discours que monsieur legault tient
depuis un bon bout de temps travaillons
sur ce qui nous rassemble c'est à dire
la constatation qu'il y à du racisme au
québec mais qu'il n'y a pas de racisme
systémique car tout cas pas aux yeux du
gouvernement alors oui j'ai gmt à el
kamel met de la pression sur le
gouvernement c'est une voix de plus
certains points seulement mais aussi
escalettes outrepassé son mandat de
corner qui est d'identifier les causes
d'un décès que certains pourraient se
demander si elle était en train de faire
de la politique on n'en est pas là selon
ma compréhension au gouvernement et le
procès décision la coronaire elle aimait
ces recommandations et le gouvernement
réagira mais tout indique qu'il ne
changera pas son fusil d'épaulé sur
cette question mais le gouvernement
sébastien a toujours eu comme ligne de
défense ou 2 2 contre argumentation que
c'était une question c'est du racisme
systémique qui divise or les voix se
multiplient dans le sens contraire il a
élargi sa tige bien à l'ensemble du pays
il grand fédéral aussi qui va dans ce
sens là
oui et c'est assez clair pour le
gouvernement fédéral c'est clair pour
certains partis d'opposition aussi comme
le parti libéral du québec solidaire
monsieur legault selon ma compréhension
reste convaincu qu'une majorité de
québécois pensent pas que de racisme
insisté mais qu'est-ce qui se base sur
des sondages il aime beaucoup faire ça
en fait je pense qu'il fait le calcul
c'est peut-être pas le calcul mais le
constat où ils pensent que ça ne
changera pas grand chose
en terme de deux changements dans la
société québécoise s'il reconnaît le
racisme systémique ça change quelque
chose s'il combat ou s'il essaie de
combattre le racisme mais d'ajouter le
mot systémique à ce combat ne change pas
grand chose à ses yeux alors que la vie
de monsieur trudeau la suite assez clair
madeleine il ya peu de doute là dessus
depuis un bon moment déjà oui mais
n'empêche que justin trudeau quand même
eu une semaine qui a été passablement
difficile surtout quand je dirais hier
en fait avec cette journée sur la vérité
et réconciliation la toute première
journée fédéral justin trudeau qui est
bon généralement sur ce terrain-là bon
dans les symboles bon dans la façon de
de parler de dire dire les mots qui
plaisent par exemple à la communauté
autochtone et là hier bon il était
absent lors de cette journée la toute
première qui avait été décrété par son
propre gouvernement
donc il est un plus placé lui aussi dans
une situation qui est un peu
embarrassante aujourd'hui et on sent que
son bureau essaie de rectifier le tir en
disant il ya quelques minutes on a eu
une déclaration de son bureau disant je
justin trudeau avait parlé à la cheffe
de kamloops qu'ils comptent aller sur
dans la communauté c'est cette
communauté souvenez vous on avait
découvert l'an tout premier tout premier
lieu et tombe anonyme sur le site des
pensionnats autochtones donc même justin
trudeau s'est retrouvé dans une position
un peu embarrassante dans cette journée
qui demandait de la sensibilité je parle
de la journée d'hier avec la question de
de toute la question de la vérité des
réponses et de la réconciliation et
justin trudeau a fait parler lui
finalement pour les mauvaises raisons
hier lui qui aime les symboles bon ont
raté une occasion de d'utiliser une
journée qui aurait pu être symbolique il
ya un principe art politique assez
simple faut que les bottines suivent les
babines
alors si vous tenez un discours de
réconciliation faut que vos bottines
soit là quand c'est le moment où
souhaité la réconciliation or les
bottines et été ou sur l'image de
finhaut elle était sur la plage de
tofino exactement c'est nos collègues de
globo je pense qu'ils ont aimé le jeu
trudeau là bas c'est quand même
particulier c'est justin trudeau à la
suite de la découverte des tombes
anonymes dans les pensionnats qui
décrète que le 30 septembre sera une
journée nationale de la vérité de la
réconciliation un jour férié fédéral et
la sieste ou oui à une cérémonie je
pense que c'est les images du mercredi
soir où il est là il est bien présent
puis bon il tire toutes les bonnes
ficelles mais le jour où on commémore la
mémoire donc des pensionnats d'aider des
enfants dans des pensionnats notamment
qu'on veut faire de la vérité la
réconciliation
il n'est pas là il a beau être au
téléphone pendant huit heures de temps
avec des avec dédé des survivants avec
des enfants de survivants on lui a
reproché de ne pas être là au cénotaphe
par exemple le jour du souvenir et
d'être plus tôt au téléphone avec d'aidé
des vétérans il fallait qu'il soit
présent il a même refusé d'aller
semble-t-il à kamloops et les décliner
une invitation qu'il avait hier hellal
son entourage et c'est je pense de
remettre la pâte dans l'entourage qui
aurait pu quand même prévoir le coup là
c'est une question de jugement politique
nom d'une certaine façon oui et lorsque
sébastien dit bon c'était le double
gouvernement qui avait des traits
décrété cette journée là c'était une une
des recommandations de la commission de
vérité et réconciliation sur les
pensionnats autochtones et en à 94
recommandations et lorsque justin
trudeau
a pris connaissance de ce rapport là en
2015 il a dit moi je les accepte toutes
ces recommandations là on s'entend que
décrété un jour férié c'est pas
nécessairement la recommandation qui est
la plus difficile à mettre en place il y
en a une série d'autres qui porte sur
l'éducation sur la justice sur la santé
donc des recommandations qui sont plus
complexes
pour qu'ils peuvent prendre plus de
temps plus de négociations donc là un
jour férié c'est pas nécessairement ce
qui est plus compliqué d'où l'importance
de donner de mettre tout le symbole
derrière cette journée qui doit être une
journée de réflexion et c'est un peu ce
que des autochtones et le parti
conservateur ont reproché à justin
trudeau c'était de dire c'est une
journée de réflexion c'est une journée
de commémoration c'est pas une journée
de vacances donc d'une certaine façon
justin trudeau a envoyé le mauvais
signal dans cette journée loeb même s'il
était là la veille même s'il a parlé
effectivement au téléphone comme les
comme disait sébastien je pense que ce
qu'on va retenir de lui et de cette
journée là c'est qu'il n'était pas et
qui n'a pas participé aux commémorations
il se serait peut-être bon et puis on
apparaît peut-être un peu moins s'il
avait un a dans son bulletin de
réconciliation il a promis de donner de
l'eau potable à toutes les réserves
autochtones au cours de son dernier
mandat sauf erreur je pense il n'a pas
fait une des cités et l'hélico muholi
nation autochtone disent que c'est
difficile le processus de réconciliation
que ça va pas assez vite alors oui c'est
exactement la même chose ici en pensant
à québec là il ya beaucoup de reproches
ou de critiques qui sont faites
notamment sur l'implantation des raids
et des recommandations du rapport
revient sur les relations entre les
autochtones et les services publics
c'est comme si ça va pas assez vite si
laisser les gouvernements étaient en
avant de la parade était avait bon une
bonne feuille de route c'est autre chose
ce serait autre chose ça n'empêche pas
que monsieur trudeau a réduit y être
fière mais peut-être que ce serait moi
est grave comme ça exactement quand je
dis ça sera autre chose au niveau des
perceptions moi le symbole puisque au
final ce dont on parle c'est ce qui
reste dans les esprits après donc cette
absolue en politique on dit quoi la
perception devient la réalité c'est ce
que vous aviez écrit dans un nouveau
livre en ce sens
on est des livres à venir on les attend
avec impatience on poursuit maintenant
juste pour clore la parenthèse
me disent c'est aussi important tous à
ceux dont on parle
alors que monsieur trudeau entreprend ce
que plusieurs perçoivent comme étant le
début de ce qu'il va vouloir laisser
comme l'inde comme héritage politique et
les la question autochtone est au coeur
de tout ça pour suivre maintenant avec
les aime les relations québec qu'à
ottawa qui ont aussi un peu de sable
dans l'engrenage ce n'est pas toujours
facile notamment l'appui de monsieur
legault conservateur qui me ne passe
toujours pas n'est ce pas oui on en a eu
un exemple peut-être avec steven
guilbault enfin sur les applications
malhabile de
monsieur legault sur est ce que le 30
septembre devrait être au québec une
journée fériée comme ça les eaux
fédérales pour la vérité et la
réconciliation monsieur legault a
répondu en continuant à marcher dans le
corridor que on a besoin de plus de
productivité laissant entendre que s'il
y avait un jour férié de plus la
productivité au québec où l'économie en
souffrirait
monsieur guilbeault le ministre du
patrimoine parce qu'il est toujours
minées du patrimoine a dit qu' il était
sidéré par la déclaration du premier
ministre donc c'est quand on a comme
l'impression que à cause de la prise de
position de monsieur legault pendant la
campagne électorale les libéraux
fédéraux en laisseront pas passer
beaucoup
notamment dans la rhétorique politique
et on a eu l'exemple avec que steven
guilbeault
je comprends quand même sébastien que
cette réaction là elle a été donnée ou
offertes à chaud j'en ai parlé à mon
collègue louis blouin le questionner
monsieur guilbeault hier et il lui
apprenait en ski c'est parti il lui
apprenait les commentaires de françois
legault donc il aurait eu cette réaction
là véritablement à chaud ça veut pas
dire que les relations sont pas plus
difficiles quand même entre québec et
ottawa moi ce que je comprends c'est que
de l'entourage le deux ministres c'est
que le gouvernement trudeau ce lève pas
le matin en se disant bon comment je
vais nuire à françois legault
aujourd'hui donc parce que nuire à
françois legault pourrait utilement
nuire aux québécois donc y'a quand même
cette sensibilité là d'essayer de ne pas
nuire ultime en aux québécois avec des
béquilles avec une psy chic and co mais
j'avais comme la loi mais ce qui s'est
passé en
finalement donnant l'appui tacite
aéronautique dans la campagne électorale
aux yeux de certain c'est que ça nuit au
ministre québécois de revendiquer des
des gains politiques pour les québécois
si françois legault fait des demandes
peut-être que c'est plus difficile pour
les québécois au cabinet de faire des
revendications pour le québec et de
l'est de négocier ses revendications la
avec les collègues or québec parce que
la stratégie c'était toujours une
stratégie d'apaisement pour essayer que
françois legault soit un acteur très
présent dans une campagne électorale
comme ça s'était passé en 2019 mais en
2021 malgré tous les efforts du
gouvernement trudeau françois legault a
été un acteur dans la campagne
électorale
donc ce que peuvent des ministres dans
le gouvernement trudeau peuvent se dire
maintenant bon finalement françois
legault ce qu'on soit gentil ou pas avec
lui s'il va se mêler de la campagne
électorale donc peu importe qu'on fera
ça changera rien donc vous voyez on
essaie je pense que c'est plus difficile
pour les ministres québécois d'essayer
de de continuer à utiliser la stratégie
d'apaisement alors par des ministres
évidemment sortant on n'en connaît pas
la composition du conseil des ministres
qui sera annoncé on ne sait pas non plus
précisément mais dans quelle mesure
madeleine le québec devra où sera
représentée de quelle façon quel sera le
calcul politique derrière tout ça avec
en toile de fond cette tension convient
d'évoquer
encore une fois j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils auraient moins de québécois à
cause l'achitecture ottawa mais je
disais ce matin à la radio il ya une
règle quand ce que j'ai déjà croisé
règle des 3 g la règle des 3 g pour
déterminer qui va siéger au cabinet
trudeau donc il ya le genre iljo la
géographie et il y avait gerald butts à
l'époque qui était l'ami personnel et le
secrétaire principal de justin trudeau
gerald butts n'est plus dans l'équipe
trudeau mais je j'avais ajouté un g moi
ce matin dans une chronique en disant
bon mais qu'est-ce qu'il va qu'est ce
qui va arriver au g2 guilbeault ou
est-ce qu'il va aboutir steven
guilbeault justement dont on parlait
tout à l'heure steven guilbeault qui
était à patrimoine canadien donc est-ce
que justin trudeau qu'il veut on parlait
du legs de justin trudeau tout à l'heure
il ya la question autochtone y les
garderies le blog aussi l'environnement
donc est-ce qu'on va vouloir placer
steven guilbeault à l'environnement un
environnementaliste
ça pourrait être vu du côté de
l'industrie pétrolière et gazière comme
un affront mais est-ce que justin
trudeau savall embêter ça est-ce qu'il
va vouloir être prudents ou pas donc
leur rôle de steven guilbeault c'est un
des premiers qu'on va vérifier sinon
bien il ya toute la question du genre
c'est un peu compliqué pour justin
trudeau parce qu'il a perdu 4 farine a
perdu catherine mais cana qui a décidé
de ne pas se représenter il ya trois
femmes qui ont été défaites donc il doit
trouver des femmes en alberta il ya
maintenant des députés mais ce sont que
des hommes en nouvelle écosse il a perdu
une femme alors il il y à une femme qui
a été élu en nouvelle écosse mais contre
cet homme donc voyez vous parfois le
genre et la géographie dont je parlais
ne s'imbriquent pas toujours très bien
donc cette parité que justin trudeau
veut donner à son cabinet il va falloir
qu'ils fassent des calculs au québec
entre autres en ontario aussi pour la
trouver j'adore la règle du 3 gbl est
excellent ce gel est tout à fait vrai
j'espère qu'il ya un peu de c'est aussi
là dedans de compétences aussi pour être
nommé à certains postes minutes
oui on l'espère tous en ce qui concerne
ce c'est un petit mot là parce que il
faut qu'on en glissant un mot aussi
bastien on parlait tout à l'heure des
dossiers sur lesquels pour lesquels il
ya la pression qu'elle demande sur
monsieur legault et les troupes khakis
le gouvernement québec est ce que le
troisième lyon fait partie parce
qu'aujourd'hui québec solidaire en a
rajouté une couche encore une fois on
sent qu'on veut en faire un enjeu
d'importance dans le débat politique
dans les joutes politiques ici québec
solidaire très certainement
ici dans la région de québec monsieur
legault est persuadé que la majorité des
gens sont en faveur le problème de
françois legault c'est investir autant
d'argent 9 10 milliards de dollars dans
un projet qui sert surtout québec et
lévis alors que l'argent des payeurs de
taxes bien de l'ensemble du québec il a
passé a pas l'air de le refroidir ce qui
pourrait le refroidir par exemple si le
gouvernement fédéral qui sont en avance
pas les 40% qu'il réclame au
gouvernement fédéral piliers aucune
garantie la tuque qui en portion du
projet sera financé par par ottawa donc
québec solidaire en particulier pense
avoir un os à ronger en herbe
environnementales notamment mais pour
l'instant monsieur legault il maintient
le cap à ma connaissance comme inclus
racisme systémique alors merci beaucoup
ont survécu rapidement la semaine
prochaine moi je surveille mardi le
premier caucus conservateur donc c'est
un caucus important pour irène roulent
tous les joints des mesures sanitaires
dans les grandes salles de spectacle
vendredi prochain dans une tout est là
que ça commence merci beaucoup bonne fin
de semaine chez reconnaît grübel au
revoir au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
[Musique]